I gotta say real quick I'm reading Scott
Horton's pre-release of his new book
it's like 500 pages on the history
between uh Russia and Ukraine it's
incredible but the reason this
correlates and there is a correlation
he breaks down all of the color
revolutions that happened through the
Eastern Bloc Nations that were CIA
backed and I can't tell you how
reminiscent it was of living through
2020. and it just it strikes me as a
color Revolution I'm not saying it was
one but it felt a hell of a lot like one
when you read about them it's crazy it's
uncanny honestly what defines color
Revolution usually they're labeled by a
color so it'll be like the orange or the
rose or the red and things like that so
um but there's a Litany of them that
happen in Eastern Bloc Nations like the
break-off nations from Russia after the
fall of the USSR and
usually it deals with
electoral processes that are manipulated
in some fashion I'm not saying that's
what happened in America but that is
what the the CIA was